my talk of the table is Kareem
abdul-jabbar and his response he's one
of the greatest basketball players of
all time his response to what's happened
the NBA's all-time leading scorer has
also been a social and political
activist throughout his career he
boycotted the 1968 Olympic Games and
supported Muhammad Ali's decision to
refuse to fight in the Vietnam War in a
very powerful op-ed that was published
Saturday in the Los Angeles Times the
best-selling author defended the
nationwide protests against police
brutality first on CBS this morning
we're very happy to say that Kareem
abdul-jabbar joins us from his home in
Newport Beach California it's really
good to see you Kareem abdul-jabbar let
me just say your your op-ed brought
tears to my eyes it the headline is
don't understand the protests what
you're seeing is people push to the edge
and I had to stop for a second and take
that in and I love how you started the
op-ed you talk about the differences
between the way black people and white
people may be perceiving this including
the Central Park jogger case the Central
Park woman can you just give a couple of
examples in the point you were trying to
make here well I think I can ask a
question and I think that would really
crystallize everything everybody I think
remembers what Colin Kaepernick went
through and his protest
was a peaceful protest about this very
issue and he was ostracized he lost his
job and he was blackballed for it that
was peaceful protest that's what it got
him that that's the benefit that it got
him and nothing has changed since then
think about this nothing has changed
since what was supposed to be a routine
traffic stop of Rodney King that was 30
years ago and still nothing has changed
white cops still can act with impunity
and and killed people that they feel
like they want to kill it's it's got to
stop someplace and powerless people have
no voice
a lot of them are losing their
opportunity to vote because the
Republicans are working very hard to
limit voter participation so what tools
do these people have to affect change
think about that means to change they
can't accept that I do think for the
first time a lot of people are thinking
about it you say black protesters are
people pushed to the edge not because
they want bars and nails so nail salons
open they just want to live and to
breathe racism in America you said it's
like dust in the air explain what you
mean by that well it's just like if you
have you ever been in a room and there's
something you feel a little something
it's in your nose there's something in
the air a dust or pollen that you can't
see but if you take a flashlight and
shine it to the air you see all these
little dust motes in the air and little
particles of things racism is like that
it's it's ingrained in our society and
it's taken for granted and all of the
things that are taken for granted can
accumulate and be deadly on certain
segments of the population and that has
and it comes down on the heads of poor
people and people of color you say for
those who say the looters are hurting
the cause you said you're not wrong but
you're also not right and I think it's
so important Kareem to make the
distinction between for the most part
these protests are peaceful but where a
lot of attention is focused on the
looting and the burning of the police
cars and I just don't want the message
to be lost about what is at stake here
and what people are really talking about
so you say you're not wrong but you're
not right either yeah I think we have to
look at it that way because these are
people who do not have any opportunity
to to have their voice heard and have
someone react to it and with respect and
appreciation of what they're saying they
do not have that power they're powerless
and
I just I have this vision of a sign that
I saw in Minneapolis that said can you
hear us now
that got to me was very significant I
mean that I think that's what it's about
we remember in 1968 when you boycotted
the Olympics what do you think that what
do you think this current generation can
learn from what you experienced what
differences do you see well I think that
this current generation has to
understand that they have to cross the
finish line with what needs to be done
and that's going to take a lot of
determination in organization are they
gonna have to get out and vote and make
their voices heard in a way that can
affect change you know violence and
looting and burning might get you some
attention but it's not going to change
anything
significantly so people that are doing
that really have to realize that and
they have to step up and organize and
both yeah killer Mike was very very
powerful over the weekend where he said
anger is not a strategy the mayor of
Atlanta said protests you need a plan
you can't just start marching in the
streets it sounds like you're saying the
same thing too you need to have a
strategy you need to have a plan we have
to have a plan and we have to engage our
fellow citizens and get them to do
what's right because too many times we
find out too late that the American
people are behind law and order in a way
that can benefit all Americans that
that's not a foreign subject to them but
they don't understand the difference
between what they experienced and what
the average person of color experiences
and that that needs to be underlined at
this point I love how you ended the
peace Kareem you said you do not want to
rush to judgment you want to rush to
justice what does justice look like to
you
oh well I think justice will look like
maybe reinforcing the consent decrees
that have been sent out to a number of
police departments to change their
culture and trying to get involved in
the escalation the Supreme Court is very
tough on people who try to get counts
get cops to be held accountable I think
you know a lot of those decisions we
have to find a legal way to deal with
cops with bad cops you know the good
cops the overwhelming majority of cops
are good cops and they need to be
protected and you know in all of this -
because they have a very important job
so you know we you know we got a lot of
work to do
and all of us have to be infinite every
American yeah and I think it's also
important to point out that most police
officers men and women are really
dedicated to their job and want to do
the right thing and most of them do the
right thing what we don't want is for
people to start vilifying cops and all
of this and you see the police coming
out to support the protesters and
numbers that most people have never seen
before I think that's important it's
absolutely important girl it's something
that has to be done and all of us all
Americans have to come together and and
and push this make make something happen
it's so clearly in front of us that this
is a this issue has to be dealt with I
hope things are different this time I
want to thank you Kareem abdul-jabbar
for your time and may I just say this
has nothing to do with the interview you
have one of the best decorated
backgrounds in your home I've ever seen
it's very pretty
so Bravo to you and your decorating team
whoever that is it's beautifully
beautifully done I'm gonna call and get
some tips on that thank you sir